hey guys hey what's up guys my name is
the Cherno and welcome back to my say
class class series so today possibly the
most important episode in this entire
series we're going to talk about
pointers now fortunately pointers are an
area that a lot of people struggle with
so I just really want to say don't worry
you don't over think hip pointers are
actually really simple and I also want
to mention that today we'll be talking
about Raw pointers not smart pointers if
you don't know what smart pointers are
don't worry about that we'll get it back
in the future computers deal with memory
memory is everything to a computer if I
had to name the single most important
thing in programming it would probably
be memory when you write an application
and you launch it that entire
application gets loaded into memory all
of the instructions that tell the
computer what to do in the code that
you've written all of that gets loaded
into memory that's how the CPU can
actually access your program and start
executing its instructions when you
create a variable when you load in data
from disk everything gets stored in
memory there is nothing you can do if
you do not have memory and pointers are
extremely important for managing and
manipulating that memory so what are
pointers I'm only going to end up saying
this multiple times throughout the
course of this video a pointer is an
integer a number which stores a memory
address that is all that it is I don't
wanna get too deep into how memory
actually works in a computer I might say
that for another video
but simply put your memory inside your
computer is just like one big blob it's
like one big line that's all it is
picture one is straight if if your
entire city that you live in just had a
single straight and there was a start
and there was an end and then you had a
bunch of houses there were no houses
across the road let's just say there's
just a street and there's like a row of
houses that is what memory is in a
computer it's just a linear
one-dimensional line and every house on
that street is going to have a number an
address so bring that metaphor back to
computers picture that every house on
that street that has an address is a
byte it is one byte of data we obviously
need a way to be able to address all of
those bytes
all those houses on our
read because for example let's say
someone orders something online and
wants to have it delivered it needs to
be delivered into the right house or
maybe someone's sending something
they're sending something away from
their house either way you need to be
able to read and write from memory from
those bytes of memory from those houses
so a pointer is that address is the
address that tells us where that house
is where that specific byte of memory is
and that's extremely important because
pretty much everything we do in our code
is going to be reading or writing from
and to memory now of course it's
perfectly possible for you and C++ to
write an application that does not use
pointers that's you can do that you
don't necessarily need to use pointers
however they are an extremely useful
tool because as I just mentioned memory
is probably the single most important
thing you have the single most important
resource that your computer can provide
to you it's used for everything and
being able to have more control over
that memory is vital all right anyway to
reiterate a pointer is just an address
it is an integer which holds a memory
address that is all that it is forget
types right types have nothing to do
with any of that types are just some
kind of fiction that we've created to
make our lives easier it doesn't matter
if you have an int pointer or maybe you
have an entity class and you have an
entity pointer it doesn't matter types
types are completely meaningless right a
pointer for all types is just that
integer that holds a memory address
that's all that it is let's jump in and
take a look at some examples ok so here
in visual studio about an extremely
simple project it's just one source file
everything that you see on the screen is
the complete code that I've got written
so let's go ahead and create a point and
we're going to create the purest of
pointers because it's going to be
something called a void pointer void
basically means that it's completely
typos remember remember I said that a
pointer is just an address it's just an
integer which holds an address in memory
so it doesn't need a time if we give a
pointer a type we're just saying that
the data at that address is presumed to
be the type that we give it right it
doesn't mean anything
apart from that it's just something that
we can write to make our lives easier
syntactically like in
actual source code to make our lives
easier we can use types with pointers
but again a type does not change what a
pointer is a pointer is just a memory
address it's just an integer so a void
pointer means that we do not care right
now in our source code what type this
actual data is because we just want to
really hold an address let's go ahead
I'll call it PTR or pointer for short
and I'll set it equal to 0 so what is 0
we've given this pointer and memory
address of a 0 what does that mean well
0 isn't actually a valid memory address
memory addresses do not go all the way
down to 0 because 0 is invalid and what
that means is that this pointer is not
valid being not valid is a perfectly
acceptable state for a pointer but all
I'm saying here is that 0 is not a valid
memory address we can't read from or
write to a memory address of C or if we
try and do that our program will crash
so 0 means null and we can actually also
write it like this which is actually
just a hash define if you look up what
bad null actually as you can see it's
just a hash to find for 0 so it's the
same as if we write 0 all we can use
this a puff-puff keyword called null
pointer this was introduced in the Sabre
plus 11 so awesome we've made our first
pointer it is completely typeless and it
has the memory address of 0 completely
useless but it's a pointer and it's
probably the simplest point you could
write let's do something a little bit
more useful let's create an integer so
I'm going to create a variable I'm going
to call it bar and I'm gonna set it
equal to a it's going to be an integer
now this is just a normal integer but of
course every variable we create has a
memory address because we need a place
to store that variable so what if I want
to find out what the memory address of
that variable is so where are you in
memory I can do that by using the
ampersand operator so if I use an
ampersand in front of an existing
variable like this we're essentially
asking this variable hey what is your
memory address and then of course we're
taking the memory address of that
variable and in this case assigning it
to a new variable called pointer and
that's it we've now got the memory
address of our variable and we're
storing it in another variable which is
a pointer I'm going to put a breakpoint
on this line of code and hit f5 to run
and debug my application so right now if
I take a look at what we've got we've
got a variable you can see by helping my
mouse over it it has the value of
and if I hover my mouse over pointer it
has a slightly different value which is
presented to us in hexadecimal format
but it is as you can see it's still just
a number it's an integer so what that
point of variable is holding now is the
memory address of that van variable and
that's all it is that number that you
see there a zero fb6 for that is where
in memory we are storing our integer
variable and in fact what I can do is I
can grab this I can copy it I can hit
debug Windows memory memory 1 so what
this view is showing now is all of the
memory inside our application I'm going
to paste in that value I'm just going to
get rid of that pointer at the beginning
there and then I'm gonna hit enter and
check this out
we are taken to this memory address we
know an integer is 4 bytes of data and
look at that it has the value 8 we're
looking at our computer's memory right
now and we can see that add that memory
address we have the value 8 because we
created that variable and we set its
value to 8 all right fantastic so that's
really I mean on a basic level that's
all there is to it everything else
builds from this if you know this much
and you're following me in your
understanding that's there's no magic
behind it that's how points were a
pointer is a variable which holds an
address an integer a pointer is like any
other variable this is with instead of
holding your values such as a it's
holding a memory address which a memory
address is also value it's also an
integer now how big that integer is how
big that pointer is it depends on a lot
of things it could be a 32-bit integer
it could be a 64-bit it could be a
16-bit integer doesn't matter right the
point is it is an integer and that is
all it's ever going to be if I go back
to my code here and I change this to be
an int pointer I'm not actually changing
anything if I run my application again
you'll see it's not going to be any
different if I go ahead and I copy that
value I'll copy the value I'll paste
into my memory of you and I'll hit enter
you can see it's still set to a I could
go back here I could make this a
completely different type such as a
double of course it's going to give me
an error this time because the compiled
is going to warn against that I can just
cast it to a Dumbledore doesn't matter I
can I'm gonna run my code again I'm
going to look at the value I'm going to
copy the value I'm going to paste it
over here and get rid of all this other
junk at the end hit enter and look at
that it takes me to that place in memory
where I'm storing my daughter and there
are four bytes there that have the value
eight types do not matter it types it
useful for manipulation of that memory
so if I want to read and write to that
memory types can help me out because the
compiler will know for example that an
integer is supposed to be four bytes so
when I try and set a value there it will
set four bytes of memory but ultimately
types are completely meaningless and in
future videos we're going to take a look
at that even more deeply but for now
just don't worry about bugs all right so
let's go back to having our void pointer
right why wouldn't you always use the
void pointer well suppose that I wanted
to get access to my data I've got a
pointer which is pointing to that data
however now I want to actually write to
or read from that data so that variable
is holding the value eight I want to
change that how do I change that how do
I I've got I know where the data is but
how do I get access to it that's where
the referencing comes in so we've gone
from a var to a pointer to var but how
do I come back to that bar well you can
do that by sticking an asterisk at the
front of your pointer so in other words
if I write this I'm actually
dereferencing that pointer which means
that I'm now accessing the data I can
either read from or write to that data
so I could for example write the value
10 in here however if I try and do that
you'll see that I'm actually getting an
error why because we've said that point
this pointer is a void pointer which
means that I mean how how does computer
possibly going to write the value 10
into a void point it doesn't know what
it is is that 10 a short which is a 2
byte integer is it an int which is a 4
byte integer is it a long long which is
an 8 byte integer we don't know how many
how many bytes of data should this right
right we've just said it's 10 but 10
could mean anything really
that's what types come in we need to
tell the compiler actually know this is
an integer so I expect you to write 4
bytes in please let's just go ahead and
change this to int and now of course
we've told the compiler this is an
integer
we've told the compiler the compiler
hasn't been like yeah
this is correct we've told the compiler
if we make mistake if we say this is
actually a double we could be trouble if
I then output the value of var which as
you can note is my original variable
you'll see that the value that I get is
10 okay so we've successfully changed it
from 8 to 10 and if we go ahead and we
set another breakpoint over here and run
our program I'm going to come down here
and to watch and actually put in that
points up and then I'm just going to
drag the value all the way up here so
that we go to that spot of memory you'll
see that at that memory we're storing 8
if i hit f10 to advance my program 1
line you'll see that now is changed to 0
a a of course is hexadecimal for 10 so
you can see that by dereferencing a
pointer and writing to it I'm basically
accessing that data in this case I'm
writing to the data at that memory
address all right cool so you should now
know how pointers work that's really all
there is to them a pointer just points
to a location in memory some people say
that it points to a block of memory
although this isn't really accurate
because we don't know how big that block
of memory is in this case it's four
bytes short because we've credit an
integer and an integer is 4 bytes of
memory so we do have a pointer that is
pointing to essentially a blocker for
bias however there's nothing in the
actual pointer which says how big the
memory is when we create arrays and all
that it does kind of keep track of the
size I'm not going to talk about that
but simply put we don't know how big the
pointer is we don't know how much data
it's holding because it's not holding
data right a pointer is just an integer
which is a memory address that's it now
so far we've been directly creating data
on the stack if I create a variable like
this we're creating it in the stack
portion of our memory I'm going to be
talking about the stack and the Cape and
all that in a later video there might be
like an annotation or something on the
screen if I've already made that video
so go ahead and check that out if you
want more details but what I could do is
create a variable on the heap or in
other words I could ask our computer hey
I want you to allocate some memory for
me and I want it to be a certain size so
what I could do for now is use a char
star now we know we know that a char is
one byte right so when I ask something
like this like I'll call it a buffer
I'll set it equal to a new char of size
eight what I'm really asking for is
eight bytes of memory
this has allocated 8 bytes of memory for
us and is returning a pointer to the
beginning of that block of memory I
could then use a function called mem set
which basically fills a block of memory
with data that we specify it takes in a
pointer which is going to be the pointer
to the beginning of the block of memory
it's going to take in a value such as
zero and then it's going to take an
aside so how many bytes should fill in
this case we know that we have eight
bytes let's run this program I'm going
to take this now you'll see that this
has the memory address over here now you
already know how memory does work and
all that so I'm just going to type the
actual variable name buffer up here and
hit enter and you'll see that look at
this we've got eight bytes of memory in
a row of course that are all set to zero
because that's what we've done with our
memset in this case because we use the
new keyword and this data is actually
heap allocated we should also delete the
data when we're done with it and we can
do that just by typing and delete we
know it's an array we use the array
operator to allocator so we should use
the delete keyword with the array
operator and then delete that buffer if
we were being super nice however a
program does finish yet anyway the point
of this example was just again to
reiterate that this is a pointer we've
said here that we want to allocate 8
chars of chars one byte so thus we've
allocated 8 bytes and we're storing a
pointer to the beginning of that data
one more thing that I want to mention is
the pointers themselves are just
variables and those pointers those
variables are also stored in memory
that's where we can get things like
double pointers or triple pointers are
basically pointers to pointers how does
all that work right well you just go
down a level and you're basically just
saying I now have a pointer which points
to my pointer so I now have a variable
which is storing the memory address
that's pointing to another variable
which is storing a memory address simple
right so in this example with my buffer
I could create a double pointer right
this means it's a pointer to a pointer
I'm going to call it PTR and I'm going
to set it equal to the memory address of
buffer so now this is where it gets
interesting
I'm just going to move this breakpoint
up here because I don't want to be
deleting the data just yet let's take a
look at this slowly this is the value of
pointer I'm gonna take that I'm gonna
copy it in here right now
you can see that over here we've got b8
f10 - and
zero four bytes I know that this pointer
is going to be four bytes of memory
because I'm running a 32-bit application
and in a 32-bit application a memory
address is 32 bits more on that in
another video
now because the endianness of this
computer is actually in reverse order so
if I paste this in here we actually have
to rearrange it so that it says 0 0 0 to
f1 and then B 8 at the end like that if
I hit enter look at that I'm taken to
the memory which stores this buffer of
zeros ok that's it pointers to pointers
sorted right really simple stuff so
that's it I could keep talking about
this all day but really I'm just going
to come back to saying the pointers are
just integers which store memory address
that is although they are get that into
your head I'm going to be making a lot
more videos on this topic and dealing
with things like pointer arithmetic and
more advanced kind of pointer operations
so if you're new to this channel feel
free to subscribe as you begin to use
pointers and as we begin to use pointers
throughout this series you'll get a lot
more examples and you'll see just how
powerful they are on what we can do with
them but this is the gist of how they
work don't overthink it they're really
simple thanks for watching I hope you
enjoyed this video if you did please hit
that like button you can also follow me
on Twitter and Instagram and if you
really enjoyed this video and you want
to see more videos like this you can
support me on patreon back home for that
to show no next time we're gonna be
talking about references and I'll see
you guys in the next video goodbye
[Music]
[Music]